pisa que eu tô sian sangue que nem no
vita eu quero te possui quero você
e aí galera desfraldadas boka aigast
nacional quando vocês me está tudo bem
porque tudo bem que eu estou na minha
casa de cada agente é coisa boa gente
chata gente roubava tudo veio na hora
certa pode pedir dinheiro pro pai pra
mãe a mãe da gente acorda gente com
carinho na barriga natal
quem tem razão mas não todas a corrupção
alegre disse também que uma terçadada
miné meu cachorro tem muita gente que
não sabe muita gente que chegou agora no
canal inscrito novo que não conhece a
história da minerva eu sempre quis ter
um bichinho de estimação né e aí quando
fui morar só primeira coisa que eu fiz
quando eu comecei a morar só foi pegar
um animal de estimação e esse animal foi
a minerva me lembra uma cachorrinha era
14 irmãos e aí eu amo-te elas
infelizmente como eu falei no vídeo o
ano dela não pude trazer os outros
irmãos que não tinha condição de criar
quatro cachorros de num kit net eu
sempre desde pequeno tem uma muito
grande público entrou com firme que eu
gostava mesmo de coração do animal
quando uma vez já está na casa minha
volta fazendo todos meus amigos gostava
de caçar passarinho com baladeira um
styling etapa e eu não ia ficar não
sabia que eu não gostava da passagem não
gostei de matar passarinho é como falar
que ele tá né mais vale um pássaro na
mão do que dois
baladeiro mas vale o ponto mais vai mais
vale um pop-up sinto que ele nascer
antes na nuca amarelo meu deus como é
encarar de pedreiro ferreiro é de paula
é nossa da nossa assim nunca gostei do
atalho vai lá vai eu querer desafiar a
lei do sentimento do coração pedia uma
baladeira que obama tinha um ponto de um
beija-flor de bem pertinho este mesmo
assim
já sozinho na flur aí fui lá uma maneira
bem pertinho traumatismo craniano está
naquele momento eu olhei para a minha
família os que foi meu deus essas mãos
fizestes esses passarinhos senhor e
agora que vai ser lhe um assassino e
hans até como viver com essa coisa de
ter matado aquele beijaço tava estava
pegando comigo para levar o filho assim
como no fundo só depende tanto de
passarem setor
2 você está assistindo em mãos e não
entendem que eu passei não era criança
minha mãe ontem mesmo não me amedronta
na minha cabeça do assassino e até hoje
nada me tira minha cabeça eu vou pagar
por um tema que ele passaria e aí jesus
de bom no pa
e aí como é que eu posso estar no céu
servir como a chegada ao mesmo tempo
olhar aqui o endereço windows o windows
ou recordar da rampa papá achando aqui
que é uma coisa que eu acho que sei não
é você tá me dando vontade eo beija flor
na casa da vovó que é que a gente perdeu
algumas coisas né infração de trânsito
timbu fez o outro tá agora matar beija
flor a chegada de tcheco importava o meu
combate aquela foto lá por mais o que é
verdade que você tava por causa da
criança não não não
depois de uma tecla passar nunca mais o
fim nenhuma nenhum animal na minha vida
teve uma vez que eu me jeito dentro de
um formigueiro tem xistra como eu moro
sozinho cara a mulher foi uma das muitas
coisas que não deixou cair na depressão
mas você cai assim luan de bicho embora
o cachorro e de gato na hora de cavar
vai ter uma vez na vida que a sua
solidão é ser preenchida por um animal
evitando dia com minério brincado
acordava milan bina e aí teve um dia que
ele mesmo começou a passar mal ela
começou a inspiração e só respirar um
pouco diferente sim tá eu levanto
veterinário é a de que ficar internada
acho que foi cinco dias e toda vez que
chegava em casa mineira ela vinha
correndo pra porta já sabe não tá cheio
e ela ficava rodando no corredor e
correndo e votarei votava até o terminal
de dar todas as voltas na china no dia
que a mulher foi internada que eu
cheguei em casa eu aberta porte não
tinha ninguém naquele corredor
aí o coração do ano daí mandei para
fazer os exames
tal acabou por um dia depois começou a
piorar no feito em fez o exame de sangue
e foi descoberto que ela tá um
leishmaniose popularmente chamado de
casa aquelas maior que é o canal calazar
é como se fosse um artes sob no cachorro
quando é assim é das duas você manda
matar eutánasia né no animal você gasta
dinheiro e mantêm o cachorro do jeito
que está porque é mais fácil matar o
cachorro
assim é mais fácil a isso o amor que tem
pela neve é o mesmo que um pai tem por
um filho sem mandar matar um filho seu
câncer quanto mais eu acho que não além
do mais tempo fazendo com esse vídeo
acho que é amnésia ela me lembrou de
muito momento triste não falei 'você tá
ruim está bem nossa parte não vai bem o
opash aquilo que existe um cachorro vem
cá dentro do seu colo colo é como se
tivesse um chute visto não tá unhas e
tamanhos e perfis destino também sou
vida sou cachorro não sei com quem tá
entendendo
acontece às vezes está assentada falar
bem não vai não vai passar daqui
comparável parado quem nunca mais na
minha hora chegar lá não chegar deitado
no colo tudo mudar quando começar a
passar a mão na cabeça dela tudo muda é
como se o cachorro tivesse a pra mim faz
fé em um parque e um fim mas se você
confiou em você confiou em mim e eu
confio em você né taq taq taq vinheta
cantar usando esse negócio aqui porque
época do remédio está todo mundo começa
a cair no hospital ela começa a querer
se coçar e aí féria então como esse aqui
é um ela mesma não se machucar a unita
ter vergonha ela tá bonita brinca corre
faz tudo tudo normal a a2 canela tema
não passa por contato assim não dá só
passa por um mosquito meio então já tem
uma coleira antimosquito tem problema
nenhum e tá igual quer saber você você
tem algum menor estimação
qual é o nome dele o que ele vai fazer o
que você gosta de fazer com ele comenta
aqui embaixo senna e sei que é um doce
que eu mais quero que você dê light no
vídeo as pessoas saberão para quem tem
um cachorro tem calazar e tal que cuide
bem do seu cachorro aqui não passa
durante todas pessoas que foi o caso de
ter que fazer é o tornado que seja uma
coisa bem pensada taum entregue seu
cachorro a qualquer pessoa não faça nada
que você não queira fazer a neve está
tomando todos os remédios dela e tal
está começando a ter o progresso agora
tomando remédio tomando remédio agora
toma remédio gente certo na hora certa
tomar na medida certa não tem problema
nenhum e sei se você não está inscrito
no canal ainda clique em inscrever-se
equity você está no facebook dá um
curtir e compartilhar esse vídeo também
para mais gente vitória está 'muito
obrigado' ter tido até aqui e
meu deus o cantor e que caiu é que
quando você namora de tanta bola e
ditava o amor à espera de mim já não é
um cara que sabe já em público
o time já está na minha época